we're a little more than a week away
from
Halloween and is there anything scarier
than a trans person with colored
[Laughter]
[Music]
hair yeah okay got that out of my
system this is going to be a little bit
of an odd
topic but that I've also been thinking
about for a
while now as I get into this I'm going
to be citing as few specific examples of
channels as I think I can get away with
because this is not intended to be a
takedown piece this is meant to be Broad
and overarching and I have no desire to
get into direct confrontation with
anybody it's exhausting and it's also
boring
ing but sometimes I do think
about the anti-woke
crowd I actually don't often refer to
them as the anti-woke crowd I tend to
refer to them as outrage Merchants
although to be fair outrage Merchants
aren't necessarily strictly the
anti-woke but there is an awful lot of
bleed over for my purposes an outrage
Merchant is someone whose bread and
butter is anger what they sell what they
project what they get attention for is
for being
angry and the simple truth is this is a
pretty effective strategy for building a
platform especially on some place like
YouTube there is no shortage of angry
content because anger fuels engagement
whether you agree with it or not if you
comment on it even to debunk it if you
hit the dislike button that is
engagement
so being very angry and presenting a
position that people will either
enthusiastically Embrace or angrily
attack all leads to engagement that's
why YouTube regardless of how its actual
policies are laid out and what in theory
it says it wants it's why the algorithm
boosts these people they have high
engagement by and
large but as much as I find the
existence of the anti-woke Brigade on
places like YouTube Tik Tok Twitter they
practically own Twitter at this point
literally I can't help but feel a little
bit sorry for them as infuriating as I
find
them and this has nothing to do with any
position that they take on literally
anything at any point this is also part
of why I don't intend to name any
specific channels as at least until a
little bit later when I have specific
reason to do
so
because I don't feel bad for them
because I agree with literally anything
they
say and strictly speaking what I'm about
to say that I feel bad about them for
the reason it's not strictly speaking
unique to their kind of
content but I find myself thinking it
more with
them it's the inability to
change and I'm not talking about like a
pigheadedness refusal to admit that
they're wrong about anything ever
but rather the fact that they're kind of
Trapped in their positions at this
point I need to explain what I mean by
this well uh first of all let's
acknowledge all this uh if you couldn't
guess already I'm quite left leaning
that having been said as much as some
people might decide to claim that I
Pander towards a leftist audience I
actually don't at least not
intentionally there have been more than
a few times where I have gone against
the grain of what it is believed the
woke left likes or says is good or is
bolstering not in a harsh this is crap
because it's woke way but because maybe
you know this is uh this has some
Progressive ideas but the story's crap
or the uh the even the underlying themes
kind of uh undermine themselves or
things like
that I approach things as authentically
as I can because despite what you may
think of me whether you know my work
prior to this or
not I don't come into anything that I
talk about with a set agenda of what my
conclusion is going to be I've actually
had some videos where I've pointed out I
went into this believing that I would
talk about X and come to X conclusion
but coming to a completely different one
this happened a couple years ago when I
did a video trying to tackle the
question of whether or not inclusion is
political I assumed going into that as I
was looking into it in forming my
thoughts that I was going to come to the
conclusion no it's not political and
instead the conclusion was well yes it
is but so was the deliberate absence of
them
because everything's political inclusion
is political so is lack of inclusion
anyway my point was I've had to come to
a different final conclusion because
that's what what I when I looked into
something what I found led me somewhere
that I didn't expect to go but I let it
leave me there because I wasn't coming
in with a fixed thing this is what my
point must
be I've
changed on things as I've looked into
them talked about them worked my way
through them
the thing about anti-woke content if
you've ever tried to engage with it
whether you like it or not I think you
need to kind of grant me it's
really
really really
repetitive it is hammering literally the
exact same points over and over and over
again whenever there is any minority
group represented in literally anything
be it in front or behind the camera you
scream Force diversity and wokeism and
anti-white racism and all this stuff and
it's the same
script every
time there's no room for nuance there's
no room for well this is a case where
the inclusion makes
sense they will always find
something that they will rip into
because the
outrage is the point the anger is what
they are selling more than anything else
and anger towards a very specific type
of person and a very specific type of
thought now why would I feel bad for
people like that because it traps you
it's very easy if you are trying to make
your living out of any kind of platform
like
YouTube to basically over focus on the
algorithm look for what gets you the
most clicks what gets you the most
engagement and keep doing that do it
more do it harder I know that's easy to
do because I don't do it and I'm not
trying to say that as a high and mighty
thing like let's be honest part of the
reason my channel is as small as it is
relatively speaking given how long I've
been on this damn platform part of the
reason is I ignore my algorithm metrics
well not fully but I don't decide what
I'm going to do based on
them occasionally you'll be like okay
maybe it's worth addressing this maybe
I'll put more thought into it but I'm
still not going to make a video on
something unless I actually have
something to say about it at least
that's what I try to do but if you are
someone who really dives into your
metrics really looks at what gets me the
engagement what gives me the views what
gets me the clicks what gets me the ad
Revenue it's very hard to stop doing
whatever that is and again that's true
regardless L of what your slant is
whether it's anti-woke or anything else
like if you've been around you've
probably seen occasions where creators
have tried to Pivot because they got
tired of what they were doing trying to
Pivot your channel substantially when
you are known for primarily one thing
that's hard to do no matter what you are
doing demo real Doug Walker's project
about aspiring film remakers that was
meant to be his replacement for the
Nostalgia Critic known for doing so well
that is it possible to ra IO a YouTube
series
but I think going
anti-woke traps you even more than any
kind of analytics chasing on its own
does because the audience that you are
building they're not there for you not
as a person not as a
personality they're there to get their
opinions validated they're pre-exist
opinions about the things they
hate and your job is to tell them what
they already believe is correct and to
validate their anger and if you stop
doing that they're going to leave you
now I'm very fortunate for how long I've
been doing this and how varied my topics
can actually be I have done everything
from Trope dissection doctor who dives
explicitly talking politics in terms of
lgbtq plus content I've talked about
YouTube drama which I talk about as
little as possible because honestly the
algorithm loves it when I do that but I
do not want that to become the focus of
this channel because if I were an
algorithm Chaser it would have to be
become it would have to become the focus
of this channel but people tend to stick
around I like to think because they like
me as a
presenter and they don't always
necessarily know what I'm going to
say whereas people who don't actually
watch me they assume they know what I
say and I actually have the evidence of
that on the rare occasions that they do
in fact talk about me now I don't want
to again I'm not trying to fuel drama or
anything these other uh these anti-woke
types they don't talk about me much I'm
not big enough to be worth talking about
even within the Doctor Who YouTube
Community I'm like
um medium to medium large fish in that
pond but that's a small pond
so but I've seen it happen where people
ripping into me this happened on Twitter
uh but they ripped into me and they were
actually ripping into me for something
completely unrelated to my doctor who
opinions and then somebody decided to
point out well you know what the worst
thing is the worst thing is that she
likes jod
Whitaker they misgendered me of course
but I'm not going to do the them the the
benefit of doing that but uh
here's the thing you watch my content my
Doctor Who stuff no I don't last time I
did my doctor who rankings I ranked 15
doctors she was number 13 and that's not
to knock Jody Whitaker if you like her
that's great she just didn't connect
with me it didn't
work but the point is they saw me
looking like this and the fact that I
would cosplay as her when I would talk
about her era which is something I do
for most of the Doctor Who stuff I do I
will cosplay in some fashion at the very
least I tend to put on the fourth doctor
scarf but they took those two facts and
went oh they love jod Whitaker cuz
that's their assumption CU there's no
room for nuance whereas my actual
audience who watches
me they understand the Nuance they
understand that I can take a general
dislike to the state of the writing of
something like the Chris chibal era of
Doctor Who but also find the good and do
my best to explain why I don't like what
I don't like honestly my favorite
comments to get aren't just people
saying yes I agree with what you said my
favorite comments to get are actually
when people say something along the
lines of you know I'm not entirely sure
I
agree but you did a really good job
explaining why you feel the way you do I
love getting comments like that and I
get them semi-regularly and I love
getting them because to me for my
perception of what I I'm doing what I
want my job to be my job is to not just
shout out an opinion and and hope that
people agree with me my job is to
explain why I feel the way that I do so
that even if you don't agree with me you
can understand why I feel this way
because I think there's still value in
understanding why someone might have a
different opinion to yours as opposed to
just saying this bad this good isn't it
so don't you
agree that's that's an echo chamber but
an echo chamber is to what the anti-woke
crowd gets caught in because these
audiences again aren't there for the
personalities they're there for the
messaging and if the messaging stops
being what they
want they leave even if the messaging
hasn't actually changed but they
perceive it to have
changed and here I'll say someone who's
most definitely not anti-woke Stephanie
Sterling of the gym quisition Fame
now this isn't really a disclosure thing
but just to be clear I have talked with
Stephanie before she did me the massive
favor of appearing uh in a video where I
asked them questions about coming out on
a YouTube channel that already had a
large audience and they were wonderful
in speaking to me but she and I haven't
actually talked since then so like we're
not friends I'm pretty sure they don't
even remember my name but regardless and
like that's not even a nog she's got
ADHD I've got ADHD I get it but the
thing is that Stephanie Sterling has
been saying the exact same stuff for a
long time they're a commentator on the
state of the video game industry
primarily they're also a wrestler which
is cool I just I love the side hustles
of YouTubers speaking of someone who has
multiple uh in that way especially
creative Endeavors like that but anyway
coming back to it I I've been following
Stephanie Sterling for a long time since
back when they were on The Escapist
actually how I came to know her wasn't
even through the gym quisition which is
the thing they're most famous for but
instead I got to know them through movie
Defense Force where she would defend bad
movies my point is I've been following
them for a very long time and they had a
very large they were getting near a
million subscribers when they came out
as transfem non-binary the subscriber
drop that they then suffered which has
been several
hundred, subscribers Lost It Feels Like
Only Yesterday that we were celebrating
our sub count dipping below
900,000 but here we are another 100K in
the hole now again she's not even
anti-woke never has been but what they
were for a very long time was a male
presenting loud angry voice talking
about video games now while she herself
was never right-wing that is a
presentation style that does tend to
appeal to a right-wing audience and they
were tearing into the exact same
corporations that most Gamers wanted
torn into not always for the same
reasons they wanted them torn into but
she would do that and she's kept doing
that but she's lost the subscribers
anyways her messaging has not changed so
why did everyone abandon them well not
everyone but why did such a big chunk of
Their audience abandon
them well the uh The Gamers TM are a
little bit notorious for being
susceptible to uh right-wing thoughts
talking points
ideologies once she came out the
perception of them no longer just
presenting as a man because they
aren't
well suddenly everyone started to claim
well she's Rudder she's more crass
they're they're they're just not the
same they've changed I mean yeah they're
happier but their messaging hasn't the
content hasn't substantially changed
even the presentation in terms of what
they say in the way they say it has not
really changed last generation the
company's console ports were utterly
wful embarrassingly broken Endeavors
that could very well have been caused
for a product recall given how
completely rubbish they were besides
which when most of these games let you
waste enough skill points to make your
carrying capacity unrealistic this
vicious doesn't have a leg to
stand on but they still lost several
hundred thousand subscribers because the
audience that she had built not intended
to be an anti-woke audience but was made
out of Gamers who tend to lean that way
and we kind of get to the realization
that they'd been listening to her only
for as long as they matched what that
audience wanted them to be they lost
that audience and they didn't even
change their messaging what do you think
would happen to these anti-woke crowds
if they actually changed their
messaging why would any of their
existing audience listen to them and
more to the point
why would the other side ever take them
this is where we really start to get
into it because on the anti-woke side of
things there is actually a very popular
sort of subset of anti-woke creators
people who kind of burst onto the scene
with why I left the left people who are
or at least claim to be oftentimes
they're young enough that trying to
verify what their uh earlier ideology is
is
difficult um but they will claim to have
previously been leftist but have since
been redpilled or otherwise abandoned
leftist thinking this is a very very
popular that's a very fast track to
instant recognition within the anti-woke
crowds if you are part of any
marginalized group on top of that oh
almost instant
Superstar if you are a woman if you are
black
if you are gay if you are any of the
things that are generally perceived by
the majority of the anti-woke creators
and Their audience to be the people that
are meant to be woke and you're saying
no wokeness bad actually oh they love
you they will boost you so fast there
isn't an equivalent on the other
side there isn't an equivalent of why I
left the right being a fast track back
to popularity within leftist spaces
because within leftist spaces there
tends to be a high degree of skepticism
if somebody has a past of deeply
regressive harmful conservative thought
bringing someone who's a bit of a Nazi
but working on it into diverse
communities is questionable if that's
your history the left's going to be
actually really cautious about embracing
you and some of them probably never
will whereas the right the further left
you used to be the better the more
extreme the turnaround
fantastic so you can take a harsh turn
one way but not the other there's
actually a case study for this this is
one of the few people I'm going to
mention in specific now boy if you're
not familiar with Kelly cattigan I
stopped following what was going on with
her some months back so if there are
more recent um twists and turns in all
of this that I am unaware of don't tell
me for my purposes and why I'm bringing
all this up it doesn't really matter the
um section of her story that is
illustrative of the point I'm making I
am aware of and I don't need to know
what's been going on with her since
Kelly kigan kind of blew up uh on Tik
Tok as one of those why I left the left
types in specific she's a trans woman
who is speaking out against trans
affirming health care for young people
to be even more accurate she was a
transwoman who received benefited from
and said very flatly it was good for her
that she received trans affirming
Healthcare at a young age and was saying
young people should not get trans
affirming healthare you can guess why
this would make her a big deal to the
right not just because of how far
outside of what you would expect a trans
woman to believe she was stepping but
unlike somebody like say Caitlyn Jenner
who was also very right-wing she's young
young people they skew woke so she's
young she's trans and she says trans
ideology is horrible and awful and
should be stopped oh and part of the
reason that people like her have such a
meteoric rise on the right is
because when they open their mouth they
have a tendency to piss off leftist and
there are few things the anti-woke loves
more than pissing off
leftists and they might like money a
little more than that but that's
probably the only thing they really love
it when we get angry so anyone who
pisses us off oh they're going to boost
the hell out of them she got a big boost
at first and she seem to be happy to
ride that wave to notoriety to Fame to
recognition and then something
interesting happened she started
complaining about how the conservatives
who had embraced her were misgendering
her it frustrates me that some of you
want to claim you respect me and who I
am but you go out of your way to call me
something that you know is going to hurt
me chalk that up to the uh the classic
notion of well you know yes I supported
the face eating leopard's party but I
didn't think they were going to eat my
face why would any trans person think
that because they are Towing the line of
anti-trans talking points that they
would somehow have their pronouns
respected why she thought that actually
doesn't really matter but this then led
to the thing that really makes the point
for me where I'm getting at she put out
some things claiming that the entire
pivot to the right was an act I've done
too much damage to the community to be
upset about that people have a right to
be upset with me it was all about
getting attention because saying the
things that she did well starting to say
things in that direction got her some
attention and when she went hard and
leaned into it she got a lot of
attention and so she said it more for
more attention you know maybe it was
because I I wanted attention online or
you know more attaction to my other
spicy socials but I I I really kind of
just feel like another big piece of it
was just wanting to be a part of the
quote unquote cool kids you know now how
sincere that was is very open to
question because last time I checked in
I think she was starting she was trying
to claim that that was trolling and that
that was the LIE regardless she's
revealed herself to be somebody who just
says whatever to get a reaction whether
it was saying the right-wing stuff to
get the reaction or saying that um
actual I said the right-wing stuff to
get a reaction to get a reaction some
part of this had to be said for no
reason other than to get a reaction
whichever it was doesn't matter but the
thing is I think she did lean into it
because she did get a lot of attention
very quickly but then she couldn't back
out if that was a genuine pivot and I
tend to believe that it was she learned
that she can't immediately grab the
attention of that side the way she could
the
right she tried to back out and she
couldn't
or she lied to get the attention and
troll Us
by proving that we were skeptical of
her cuz I don't know anyone who bought
that wholesale even though I tend to
believe it's the case like everyone was
still like okay prove it with time that
you're actually going to get better and
she
didn't so the reason why how truthful it
is doesn't matter is that it is still
illustrative of the point that the left
didn't Embrace her she couldn't just go
running to the other side the audience
she'd built the people who had given her
attention they were on the right and
they didn't care about her unless she
was saying what they wanted to hear now
could you make the argument they were
faster to abandon her than maybe a lot
of the anti-woke crowd which is made up
mostly of white men my age um yeah
that's probably a
factor but the thing is I have it on
pretty good authority of at least a few
of these
people who don't believe what they say
like they believe some of this stuff is
um you know is force diversity and being
done for virtue signaling or whatever
which is an odd phrase that they try and
throw at us when literally their entire
platform is built on signaling the
virtue of being anti-woke but
anyways that you know they believe some
of it but they have to say it about
everything and they don't actually
believe that now how many of them don't
actually believe it and for the purposes
of the damage that this kind of stuff
does it doesn't matter if they believe
it Kurt vonette said you are what you
pretend to be and I do think that's true
to a certain extent but my point is I
think there are some of these
people if they thought it wouldn't cost
them their
livelihood I think some of them just out
of exhaustion might soften
just a
little but they feel they
can't they have embraced and gathered
around them a
radicalized far-right angry audience and
that kind of audience is very easy to
get mad at you you've primed them to get
mad at anything that goes against how
they think the world should be
so the instant you step out of
line it's you that they're going to be
mad at the ape influencers find
themselves more and more in the same
dilemma as conservative YouTubers who
nurtured fascist audiences they need to
play to the crowd or risk being turned
on and that's why I feel bad a little
bit I feel bad for anybody who feels
trapped by their work who feels trapped
by something that ideally they started
doing because they had at least some
degree of passion for this kind of work
if not the very specific thing that they
were doing so I feel bad for them to the
same extent that I feel bad for anybody
working in animation who's trapped just
hunched over a drawing tablet and just
doing this background character over and
over and over again and feeling
unfulfilled in doing so but it's what
pays the bill so it's what they do I
feel bad for them in so far as they're
trapped under the late capitalist system
same as the rest of us that is the only
extent to which I feel bad for them but
there is something to be said
for feeling trapped by your audience I'm
very lucky because I don't I very
sincerely get to say what I actually
think on here to the point that I've
confused people sometimes I've had
people come into my comments or uh
response to things that oh bet ver is
going to hate this because they said
this in the past and then it turns out
no actually I'm okay with that and
here's the Nuance as to why I feel this
is more acceptable than that I don't
have to walk a hard line I'm not here to
sell an ideology I'm a person I can have
Nuance I can have contradiction even
because people aren't machines and
contradictions logical or emotional or
otherwise don't make my head explode I'm
not a robot but when you have built your
career to basically just be a machine
that vomits ments out the exact same
talking points video after video week
after week I mean I'm sure the paycheck
is a salv on that I personally have a
hard time imagining being happy with
that though and I wonder how many of
them might do something
different if they' known they where they
were going to end up all of them no
definitely not some of them
probably oh well what can you
do as I said I've been thinking about
this for a little while and I don't have
a grand final point to make but I just
wanted to talk about this and get it off
my
chest what are your thoughts on any of
this try not to have it turn into an
argument about any specific creators I
tried to avoid talking about specific
people as much as I possibly could
please do the same if you can help it
just because I don't need inter fandom
fights in my comments they're exhausting
to moderate so if you can abide by that
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living but
don't worry too much about that like
share subscribe they they also help
there's links to other things in my
description but what I really want you
to
remember is that you are
beautiful you are
valid you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
time to thank some patreon backers and
in the spirit of October I'd like to
thank Robin Moore Zubin L fulla goddess
aligha tck the thing that goes dink in
the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures or bton Melinda Walters Jen
Auntie Kate 88 Becky Sparks FX The
brutal Robin Powell Tracy scrap angry
caspel Dave Hall and rosn
Bennett thank you for your assistance um
I don't know I might try theming the
shout outs in the future I don't know
we'll see thank
[Music]
you
no